[Musique]
le vieillissement progressif des
populations constitue un événement
capital de notre époque qui pose les
problèmes tant sur le plan humanitaire
que sur le plan économique milieu des
années 60 et les mêmes préoccupations
qu'aujourd'hui comment prendre en charge
les personnes âgées
car c'est bien à cette époque que
certains démographes alerte sur le
vieillissement croissant de la
population graphique de l'époque à
l'appui
si vous suivez le petit chapeau qui
disait croire voyez il suffit de
regarder
et en effet il a doublé les vieillards
sont les grands bénéficiaires des
progrès de la médecine bénéficiaires des
progrès de la médecine
mais pour une vie dans quelles
conditions oui j'aimerais beaucoup chez
nous beaucoup je ne bois jamais personne
j'aurais seul toute la journée dans son
fauteuil pas bon 12 15 heures du secteur
pour les je m'ennuie beaucoup de
personnes viennent me voir
à l'époque très peu de maisons de
retraite presque pas d'elle à domicile
les structures dédiées au troisième âge
sont rares un professeur en gérontologie
dénoncé ce manque dès la fin des années
d'autres faits réalisation au public le
privé sont à l'heure actuelle largement
dépassé par les événements et ne sont
plus suffisantes pour secourir
efficacement les différentes catégories
de vieillards doivent principalement
dans les grandes villes
un plan gouvernemental sera mis en place
dans la foulée et les constructions de
maisons de retraite vont se multiplier
mais difficile de rattraper le retard
alors que la population ne cesse de
vieillir
conséquence trente ans après les
premières alertes même refrain dans les
années à venir il va falloir faire face
pour venir en aide aux personnes âgées
une phrase qui reste toujours
d'actualité car le nombre de places en
ehpad manque surtout que selon l'insee
la part des seniors âgés de 75 ans ou
plus devrait s'accroître à partir de
[Musique]